welcome to this week's Android developer
office hours I'm rich time right I am
NOT Nick butcher you're not Luke butcher
I had an ick better isn't it all day
because of the Olympics um make any
sense well welcome to this week's
Android developer office hours we're
here to answer your questions on Android
development if you would like to join in
the Hangout please just ping on the
thread inside the Google+ on Android
developers Plus page and we'll add you
in so you can come and ask questions on
and drug development things that we
don't talk about in these sessions there
are product roadmaps future releases
other things that may be deemed
confidential it's all about the
development Android technologies and
Android devices themselves you have
something now you just do that but II
just did it like to welcome our
suffering back in again as are
definitely our most regular attendee of
these hangout sessions as well hey guys
agree oh yeah hey I should open the chat
window cuz I'll often post the most
useful links in that as we're running
through we have some viewers on YouTube
already so I guess well anything
interesting going on a lot of Android
you may talk about this or just before
we start the meeting how you mentioned
that something isn't out something
interesting for developers yeah they're
offering a remote testing lab which you
can sign up to and you can get a lot of
access to devices like the s3 galaxy
note even s two tabs 10.1 just to test
out your applications remotely so there
might be some developers who want to
play around with the s3 because it's
they were saying they've sold 10 million
of them now so it's well worth trying
out apps on it I'm from what ten million
from what I can see you get a number of
credits assigned to you and you can book
15 or 30 minutes slots and use it use
that device as you want so much like a
test Royd other cloud-based testing
solutions we've seen before that it is a
for free he said and if Samsung devices
yeah it looks like from what I've seen
they give you a certain number of
credits you can probably buy more
credits if you want more time but you
get a certain number of credits we just
think works out about four hours worth
of testing on any device that they've
got on their system and looking through
they've got s3's galaxy no Galaxy Nexus
the gala
the original galaxy s s 2 tab 10.1
various variants of them even going back
to the original Galaxy Tab 7.0 so was
reasonably high end what about the lower
and stuff I think those are often the
ones which might you know for up some
niggles on certain apps like what the
galaxy y and x and all this kind of
smaller lower end devices out how their
goodbyes register it seems more focused
on the premium offerings the galaxy s i
supposes what you could class the lowest
it appears to go to even though it sort
of was high-end a few years ago it's a
WVGA device so it gives you that 800 x
480 screen and most of the things you'll
see but it there's a limited selection
at the moment but it does very much
thing to be the higher-end offerings and
what's the URL so that see samsung that
gun yeah yep come on create your account
there and it's called the reload Tesla
looks good yeah you get out virtual
physical devices over the web that's
cool that door I think Sony well nice
any ericsson now sony Mobile looking
good office next similar don't know they
have physical you can basically borrow a
device is s excellent thanks get yeah
yeah there's a bunch of other
third-party solutions that we could
mention as well but have a variety of
handsets usually they're not free looks
like that Samsung one's gonna be free
for Samsung Developers which is
excellent whose book your time slot and
get the device yeah and the the fact
they're covering 10-inch 7-inch and 4
inch and down to I think four inches and
low as they go means you can also cover
a range of sizes if developers and
access to tablets and stuff like that it
is pretty cool that's cool I mean
anything well you know the only later
gets you love the way the screen size
testing but it's often kind of OEM
customizations so if you didn't sync
with a camera or something like that
when real devices can come in real handy
testing yeah I guess that's where it
really would help out some people so
yeah well thanks to it thanks for
bringing it up as an interesting topic
okay so we'll head into the moderator
I've put the moderator link for the
questions for today inside the Google+
post as well so you can see it there
it's also at developers.googl com
what / lie forward slash android where
you can track these events going forward
we actually have three sets of office
hours tomorrow Wednesday one in the
Asian time zone one in the European
wanted me America time zone so you can
be the switch to watch it during work or
after work which ever saw if your super
keen they did a triple you win some kind
of prize maybe but if you ask the same
question at all three betting you use
the puns just trying to use a seed you
get three different answers out of the
three if it's a great advice there's no
pregnancy no come on to the moderator hi
says some oh it's up there a friend of
mine has created his I OS application
and he wonders what ways are available
to convert it to an Android application
what is this I us other but I think it
runs on cisco Reuters creative a mobile
application for a couple and would like
spring Andrew hi maybe he doubled the
simians to do um that's not going to
impress okay so I mean the thing is to
become an Android developer really we
don't charge you to get hold of the SDK
so you can go to developer.android.com
and start looking through how to write
android applications that's going to be
the best thing to do we have a great
design site at developer.android.com
forward slash design and in there
there's some pages around pure android
which actually hint as to how things
should work across different platforms
so I'll help with redesigning the
application so it looks and fits better
into the Android ecosystem it makes use
the black bodies it's really big an
extensive topic i think that the
industry as a whole it's not trouble
with little bit and a lot of people have
looked towards html5 and other hybrid
technologies to kind of be the shining
light that kind of rides into needs say
GC only have to write at once and it
runs perfectly on every single and
different different platform out there
but i think that's never really can't
come come to pass something like if you
take a look at facebook for example used
to be the poster child this movement
where they were writing rap a lot in
HTML
and while it may have some fly the
development process I think most people
agree that it didn't yield the best
possible user experience in their
applications is interesting to see see
those guys to see Facebook turning
around and saying now that they're going
to focus on native mobile applications
so I think that kind of really speaks to
the fact that you know if you want to
have a best-in-class really responsive
beautiful application then you really
kind of need to go native it's nice new
yeah I kind of agree I mean there are
solutions which do cross platform at but
from HTML the Titanium's and phone gaps
of the world but i'm still yet to see an
application that was done with one of
those cross platform solutions that you
couldn't tell wasn't native the bounce
backs done in javascript list scrolling
things like that the native component
uicomponent across various versions of
android it always is pretty clear up
front that the application you're using
is a web-based application I HTML
cross-platform application get things
like links in apps just look massively
out place highlights kind of wrong and
spoiling is slightly off and it just
feels wrong and of course you can't take
advantage of a lot of the platform
features that Android has for supporting
multiple devices modding me 7-inch
devices lexus that's quite interesting
at your facebook at the moment i know
are hiring android engineers so they
definitely are moving away from the
html5 explorer who are they london and
live in a job posted hundred engineers
and they also bought lightbox right
which I yes an acquisition I don't know
I've heard it's a talent acquisition
rather than anything else so yeah
they're definitely taking people on so
hopefully we'll see something good from
them in the future yeah it should be
lots of reports of number of users of
Facebook that our own doing it for
mobile there hundreds of millions or
whatever it's just for mobile s ascend
in there buddy s ok we're all the
viewers today why we have viewers on
YouTube you have and what I was talking
about it uh we need two people to join
in the Hangout come along and some
questions live in yes the men's time
trial started we're almost up against
the men's time trial after we can pee
here that's weird eh can we get a second
live streaming
hang out to watch it yeah I know we need
the android-powered exercise bike from
IO 11 in Genesis good memory the adk
Android exercise bike since bringing
okay let's have a look at the next
question is really the Google Play
content policies have changed they have
indeed if you're an Android developer
would have got an email today saying
that we've updated our policies for
distributing applications in google play
those details of that inside the the
email and look through to leave with new
policy me science here developer into
the upside she can get away now yeah you
should have a top so the closet gains
incentivizing ratings on the market was
there already says matters but it was
never really enforced will it be
enforced from now on so it's a tricky
one I mean we don't look at every single
game and play every single application
in the place where we don't have people
to do that that's not how the place will
work for a much more open ecosystem
however we have systems that look
through the google play portfolio of
applications it's one of the reasons why
it takes a little bit longer the
applications to get published now and we
have the systems that are bouncer and do
I looking for malware specifically but
we also do look out for things like
applications which have a suspicious
number of five-star ratings over a short
period of time so there are systems
looking after these things and of course
we can use those to try and I like the
apps but the main point here is you're
definitely not going to get your
application featured if you have this
kind of functionality in the application
so the abscess do get for the testers
are the ones that go through featuring
an editor's choice and staff pics Lisa
there's also some subtleties in what we
kind of consider incentivizing as well
like you can say please rate my app and
the best way to do that is to have a you
know yes no never kind of thing so you
don't annoy the user popping it all the
time but you can't say please rate my up
five stars because that's trying to
influence the way to do it and you
certainly can't say rate my app five
stars to get X please
well it's just a like there's no way for
the app dash you to determine what your
wedding was so there's subtleties in
what you can and can't do in moving
Metis isn't clear about that you can
actually ask people to say please rate
my app if you find it useful and please
do that in a non annoying way and that
yeah you can't really incentivize them
to rate it a particular rating which I
imagine be classed as there is of course
the ability to report apt in the Play
Store there is indeed at the bottom of
every app listing on the mobile device
you can scroll down in the cortex and
there's an inappropriate at reform
reporting on the web store as well yeah
you really don't want to start getting
applications band three of those and you
can get your account shut down and other
things so it's just much better to abide
by the content policies that are laid
out and not try and work around them in
any way yeah they have been made more
specific in a few of these areas there I
think the changes are better i think
they clarify a lot of stuff and how to
add a few more examples about Ingrid
should have seen people confused about
the past one of the big changes seems to
be getting rid of something the bug me
which was notification adverts you get
adverse a pair of system notifications
they were just I've not met anyone who
found those as useful or actually used
them to click on without thinking that
they were something useful as in terms
of a notification from a nap rather than
an advert yeah yeah talk about
advertising one minute we'll go into
that a little bit we've made it very
specific now that adverts inside your
application let's also abide by the same
rules as your entire application you're
fully responsible for every advert
that's shown in that app so if for
example you're using advertising
platform and it enables you to turn
gambling adverts off we should turn them
off instantly because if gambling advert
start appearing inside your application
and they link through to live gambling
sites your application can get banned
from the store for that you just get
taking about people can report it what
about and we can find it so just be
aware that you are fully responsible for
every advert that shows in the app don't
put them in annoying places and don't
mislead users into cooking them buzzards
adult apps and app which is rated for
everyone else and then like that mm-hmm
they also true yeah so just be a bit
more kapler and the ads as well and this
was all covered in the guidelines before
class just very specific making a bit
clearer
okay so if anyone has any other
questions about any guidelines then
thinking through our we heart it one
month okay why not yeah from v1 p
Jonathan a new 1p asks how can i access
the phones incoming call screen activity
from my application he can't know
there's a couple of things that you
can't do that's one of the new comic
about people's phone calls together
unless you write your own fire firmware
get mobile the AOSP all right you can do
it on your own device if you really
wanted to yeah yeah I was actually some
absolutes trying to do things big clever
don't they were like by having a window
floating on top of it it was a app
through to I remember while ago which
like tried to give you extra options
when you are in call to someone so you
could easily share your location with
the sentiment image while you're on the
port of us they try to strange floaty
over the incoming call screen thing you
can't actually kind of interacting
blackberry there's nothing stopping you
though writing your own dialer
application to dial out it's just the
incoming calls you can't intercept the
right let's types an example of that
when you want to make a call if you got
skype and store that come up and say
John sir but its focal using dial-up or
strike you can register for that intent
and as well we saw our first application
today come through that was also now
registering for this action so when you
do that it now comes up and cysts you
want to use google now what you want to
use swiping up from the bottom yes the
swiping happens on motion it normally
look just Google there this devices ah
it's Jenny pinion such a great view of
what the intent was actually do this
Intendant assist please is there
documented in the in the latest i think
it was in this is also go to jamie just
run off a javadoc you'd be fine I did it
yeah why did it identified it so you
can't access the fragrance window okay
let's just go back to the thread and see
if anyone else was made a comment are
you reading app Antonia oh okay Dennis
ago if I join me to hang out Alex
who's also us inside Alaska the
moderator that free soul who is probably
the same person allott okay but asks can
I make clickable durables inside a text
view the drawable created using HTML
village theater from image is download
from the web I want to be able to zoom
the images can I make clickable
drawables from inside text view no so
I'm guessing is using you know HTML dirt
from HTML or likkle summer league by
methods try and turn summation out
except summation on text you right any
that load images it listen it not only
so Davis join the hangout Joanna explain
uhto going that's not its mustard oh
it's not oh sorry that's right but I do
have a question okay well we'll think
about Alex's question once you are you
ask yours if you look outside yeah so um
you know how they have all these phone
gaps and other AP eyes and then tools to
help you do cross platform is there any
frameworks I just the idea of a
framework of a lightweight like rapper
like maybe Google Docs does where that
um it's more of like a link like the app
icon launcher would be almost like a
link and have a lightweight amount of
metadata about the person but if you're
always connected to the web it would go
to the website and download like you no
html5 pages on there so maybe keeps your
login credentials and some metadata
about you but really it's uses the HTML
in stunning I guess in some respects the
browser does work for you anyway in
terms of keeping love you can save
logging details you can do that kind of
identification using Chrome or the
normal browser on Android so you could
just get away with making a bookmark and
then
saving that good luck to your home
screen if you wanted to go um unlike a
custom village he looks like a framework
that other people can adopt so that it
kind of the perp the user doesn't know
it looks native they think its name but
I don't know if there's something out
there I wouldn't want to go out and
create this if it already existed i
looked around but i was just wondering
if you guys knew I don't know the
specific framework but in terms of lines
of code it would be will be particularly
many are you here with you and load
things into it looks tense oh damn what
why do you want why do you want to fool
people into thinking their native that
well not full but more of you know you
have html5 people and everyone wants
their own little app everyone wants that
little icon on there they don't want
people to think oh I'm going to the web
also a lot of people want them natively
control it here's your login screen
here's some credentials and it's more of
a perception yeah it's not full but it's
more of a user perception hey I've
launched that icon you know hey I got
this app but if most of your stuff is
making JSON calls or calls to the web by
not use a common language to everyone
knows or you know phonegap does actually
let you do that it does that you have
pages which should just loaded
dynamically straight from the web ok so
these put so probably worth bringing up
web view which is an object you can use
in android where you create native app
and it uses a web view and a webview is
populated from an HTML source so you can
use that to connect back to your main
application and you can use a JavaScript
interface if you want to call into
native code so you can make some small
tweaks to make it a little bit more
native and make some use of Android
functionality without going fully down
the route of having a complete Android
application but once again is a guy said
earlier it's usually better to go down
the route of an Android app if you've
got the resources to do it its users
tend to spot html5 apps whatever you do
yeah and I was just I was just putting
that idea out there to see if someone's
done it because I and to get your input
from it cuz I was just thinking about
doing it instead of going totally native
so I mean I've always been done native
and done the JSON but eyes
well if it's outdoor if you thought
maybe it was a good idea or something
like that because I thought yeah
demikhov I would say be a bit be
cautious of doing that because let you
say everybody once you know that
experience and have an icon on the home
screen and what not but they've just
been really kind of cognitive when they
launched an app they are expecting an
experience and if what they are getting
is a web experience which is slightly
different and you know you get into this
uncanny valley where the interactions
aren't quite the same I'm use different
affinities set an expectation it's going
to work one way it's going to be really
responsive it's gonna you know if
questions are gonna do one thing rather
than have links and stuff like that so
just be real careful about mixing the
cement applause no no great thank you i
do i just something i always been on my
mind and i was wondering to do it I have
another question too but you can go to
the other guys first I'll wait nice like
they go hey listen yeah it's fun dive I
have a little app called magnifying
glass and so this app uses the camera
many different phones and even though I
say okay use the permissions and make
sure they have zoom and everything else
I've found out I've given the way that
someone can zoom is send me the
parameters of their camera and I see oh
it doesn't have a zoom or doesn't have
it doesn't support it but you know they
it still was able they were able to
download it and it's usually the cheaper
phones that doesn't work real well but I
really get a lot of people bad comments
like hey you you know I mean really some
really good ones that are pretty you
know it's free too but you know I don't
want to repeat the words and i was
wondering i'm just a i'm not a big
company and everything and I heard about
at being able to moderate or respond to
people because like I'll use a generic
term like stinks one word stinks and one
star I'd like to be able to ask a
question like why does it stink and
everything else and that's probably the
new one if you look at it that's I I
rewrote it for ice cream sandwich so
there's older versions yeah and it also
has a mirror now too yeah that's me
and you can do mere two so I did it for
my girlfriend so she can do her lipstick
now to self use the menu and but you'll
see on there that they're like some of
the focusing and other things like that
doesn't you know I have it so you have
to click on the focus something because
like Motorola is notoriously bad at
accepting the basic api's like even a
zoo like I say you know you even doing
the regular zoom so I've you know I
haven't done a board to buy that well
when I the actual the properties you
know when you have the property is you
get a set zoom and you give it to zoom
value it's I've gotten back people
saying hey it doesn't work and then I
have a friend that has a motorola fun I
can't remember the version of it and
he's like oh yeah you really have to do
a work around with the camera though you
know oh so um those camera settings
should be added to the compatibility
test suite if they're not already in
that yeah unless you should be getting
through with that those kind of bugs in
them yeah and and and I sometimes I
think it maybe it's you people just
don't know how to use it I thought it
was pretty intuitive probably is it but
I mean I would like that is there any
how do I go about I send and request
after quests um through the whole
developer store because I'm the top
level person I'm the only one on my
developer store so I wanted to do that
today site I'm through go to google to
the ether I went through the developer
store or still you know do this double
store developer store the help and that
you know what form that try to fill out
forms you know is this about there's
nothing about development you know or a
question like that ask for that directly
it's more like Oh for billing or four so
I did the jello in questions we would
definitely recommend going on to stack
overflow well the android google group
let the sec of the float but this will
be developer this is definitely just for
the store no development quick this is
just how can I have that top-level
request to talk to the people who say I
see their spines don't understand so
yeah there's no floor professor yeah
it's only
the people to talk developer bad right
now okay so um I'm but I'm the main
owner of mine so how do I can I ever get
onto that develop a is a badge awarded
to certain developers not toppers in
route of the day okay I mean one of the
things that my dear is mentioning what
the remote testing services like was it
perfecto mobile where if someone reports
a problem of the specific device you can
get some time on a device that they host
and you just get an interface to it and
you can see whether you can reproduce
the problem and then you can get a bit
of a head start and debugging it on that
specific device yeah yeah specifically
as you say I mean the top developer
badge which does at the moment get you
the respond to comments it's a simply
announce it at Google i/o we've had a
lot of requests to be top developer come
through a whole lot of requests for
people ask them to get the respond to
comments functionality and right now
it's limited to that group and we don't
have any more announcements on before
when that would be expanded it's just
you know we're developing the future and
we wanted is small so it uses to bang on
it and give us feedback on it so you
know yeah well I mean my next question
is why why can't I can anyone help me I
open source this a long time ago mm-hmm
that's on its on devout go gold you know
I have a link to it it's hosted by
google and I you know I have even both
branches we're on the ice cream and
check it in and um I don't put the code
out there and in the wild you have to
like ask to join I only have one person
ever asked to join but he never followed
through cuz I'll sweet hit but it's free
dies like I'll give you credit I'll put
it up you know all that stuff and I just
I was it's remarkable sometimes you get
people to help you know I only have a
few people that have downloaded it but
yeah I have apps with similar numbers of
downloads that are open source as well
and it's very rare that you get anyone
else just going through and deciding to
commit to the application you need to go
to user groups in your area android user
groups or google developer user groups
and then get some interest in it and
then some people who
she meet face to face maybe commit to
doing some commits yeah because it only
has like 240,000 or something like that
plus I got kicked off the group one so i
still have 30,000 from the other I IP
google slap my hand for one time sorry
about that I didn't mean to do that was
all but yeah it's not much the camera
issue I think you getting to the cool
thing is that it sounds like bugs in OEM
implementations of the camera like so
obviously not using our camera ended in
their own camera and they basically just
not really hit the whole API so the
thing you can do pragmatically is
blacklister device until you manage to
get some decent debugging and work
around it perhaps but the best answer is
rich said earlier is to submit a cts
test so this is a suite of tests which
every phone has part in order to get and
you know at the Play Store and gmail and
google maps and stuff like that so if
you go to source to android com and and
has instructed about how to write and
submit a cts test and that we're doing
everyone in the world a favor Oh awesome
yeah I'll start doing pen I have the old
one I did it I seems like the newer
phones with jelly bean because I have
jellybeans and ice cream sandwich that
they're not sending them to me and plus
I did the new UI and some people get mad
of the little icon bar but they're
getting used to it but the old one yeah
the old app I actually had a way that
you can contact me do I don't do
internet connection or anything else
like that so people like that too
because there's no advertisement no
missions is good yeah all right thank
you all right thanks for coming incident
excuse I some to hear okay feel free to
stay in as well if you want to hang out
yeah beautiful a good with the colored
said anything interesting to me in a
local industry I understand what like to
say
is it an android okay let's go back to
the moderator then someone's asking how
can i set the shooting mode for the
camera of your application interesting
well maybe David can even answer that it
seems to see ya but I've use the camera
quite a lot have you ever looked into
the different shooting modes for the
camera um yeah are you if you go to the
properties um I think it's shooting dash
dash mode so you have to go get camera
they get the properties i forget the
actual method call and then there comes
back name value pairs and it will tell
you the different modes of thing and
then from there you have to read and so
there's like a motorola there was
actually moto dash zoom and there's a
moto dash shoot their mo it's really
neat to look at some of the added
properties a lot of cameras have
horrible what are you finding those
added preferences what did you find the
motorola specific in dec bring them all
out you can do it to flatten on the
properties and that's all i do is once
you get the property you say dot flatten
it was low and it just prints out all of
them and i just take all that and I call
the email client and send those to it as
a body of message and put my email in
there and so it's up to the user to send
me it by all I tell you I get a lot so I
come in you get use a sudden listen I
get at least six a day some of them just
send me the properties with no input so
I tried to like get this whole you know
support going on my own I mean I'm doing
this for free this is my audio now Sony
but we have one of the most
comprehensive library I camera settings
ever yeah I do Robbie and I'm willing to
give it to you I didn't cuz I don't like
I don't you know I might have any you
know it doesn't give you any specific
user information it's just that you
properties amer well maybe we'll talk to
you about it after an interesting if you
could post it somewhere we could repost
it on my Google+ page yeah they're all
emails they're all emails a naive
you know I have them in gmail box just
waiting for the bug reports to come in
excellent I was quite a comprehensive as
I had faithfully for the camera question
from Andre have we got anything else
we've got some new moderator stuff that
seems to be popping up it's a
interesting one there I need to you some
hard coded credentials in my app for
example the mail address that is used to
send a bug report or the couple idkey
used 40 or is there a standardized way
to protect this data I know um yeah we
would suggest that especially thought Oh
off keys think about the potentially not
keeping them inside the application the
young and you keep model web service and
pull them in when you need them there
was a good tour from last year's i/o in
2011 the Pirates and vampires talk by
Dan Galpin they'll actually run into how
to secure data because there are things
inside LVL license verification that are
very useful to secure and that ran into
of course obfuscating your code it run
into if you really wanted to make it
more secure use the NDK and then put the
secure information in the in the native
layer and call through to it so as much
harder to luton pilot and get hold of it
I was just linked to the Python vampires
talk thank you out there's some
information on Stack Overflow if you
search for the same kind of things I had
to secure keys inside Android but as far
as the standardized I think what you're
looking for is a kind of standard your
arms but just put it in this place there
isn't actually an answer for that that I
know that it's a
up to you to let Dayton and one of the
most of your ways to do that hey C just
join the hangout oh hi guys hey Stefan I
have a short question currently I am
doing to get our application hammer a
GPU accelerated and we found several
methods which are not supported but
views acceleration especially the drop
half on the draw text on path is one of
them and we are using them do you know
any substitutions for this so we do have
a list of the methods that are supported
certainly we have it Ice Cream Sandwich
I haven't actually seen an updated list
for jelly bean have you seen one okay it
probably hasn't changed so no I don't
know of an alternative for using proper
mi rated of course you can turn
acceleration on and off around the
screen at the time that you're using
yeah he one of the sources of our
information is checking romance talk
from give io 2011 as well they have it
on display us yes the thing you can get
it rip to a bitmap once yeah basically
and then keep on throwing that like it's
not changing slowly and then I change
really understanding if the part on
which your rendering your text begging
or is it just me to render public sex
not part once and then you can just rear
ender that time um the Turks stop
changing but or the background is
changing ok I'll try this each eps
render that's a little bit not right and
then okay I've seen this from remain
that's where I can render so Goodman
yeah I've seen this top Oh what is a
colorful I think it wasn't second of all
I think yeah poachy as far as i know
nothing's changed away and even if it
had changed for jellybean you'd
obviously need to still
what the previous versions anyway I
think the major changes to harbor
acceleration and jelly bean were done
around the web view the the new web view
inside jelly bean is a lot more of the
elements in there a variety of the
previous ones and cases it's a a similar
story yeah thanks nope um just open up
hi is no you see you here as well I have
you unmute off to eat just as you
haven't any time well I just type it in
soon
yeah okay ah where are we 237 back to
the moderator what's the best channel
for suggesting ideas for Android this
one I just asked and suggested their
framework I used to come on us because
you actually get to talk directly to
Google um but salsa android com is the
place to go if there were a bit of big
change there's an Android contributing
google group which people can save big
chunks of code that they want to submit
and then they can code it up submit it
to the android open source project and
the eventual filter its way through yeah
you go into the Android discussed forum
on Google brooch and start suggesting it
in there as well all these places are
monitored by Googlers and we can have a
look Fridays but probably discussions
aren't running like breakfast okay the
Russian it's not to be relevant but the
places to go suggested that the goobers
are looking to leave a phone number get
em you can choose a type of feature
request night anything hmm looks to
publish bug tracker some sources I mean
you put the link for the source thing
yeah sure thanks sorry just so hundred
hours til ya ah yeah this is a yeah yeah
I always look then run to submit to the
open source project the source is the
instructions are on that place okay this
okay yeah I put the link to the group up
as well oh do I talk too quickly for you
don't have some submissions accepted
into AOSP right sure yeah basically if
you've got a large chunk of
functionality the best place to go to
start off his Android contrib and that's
the place where your idea gets bounced
around people then sort of tweak it to
what would fit into the Android way what
would be better suited to the current
code base once you've done that you can
submit your code to the android open
source project a lot of the stuff for
that you can get from source to android
com you submit your patches into what's
owners Garrett and that's a system where
those patches can then be reviewed by
Googlers can be approved or they can be
comment
on sometimes things that may make sense
given the current code base may get held
back because there are changes in the
internal Google repository that aren't
public yet may knock on to what you're
trying to do so once you're in Garrett
you may see things that don't make sense
at that time but in the future may make
a little more sense once those are
accepted they end up into the android
open source project code base and when
you when are you playing around with
that the best branch of the code to play
with is called the master branch because
that's where all the development goes on
once those are in there then there's a
quite good chance that they will
eventually make their way into the next
major release of Android it's also worth
noting the best time to make a
contribution is just after we've open
sourced the release that's the point at
which the public aoao SD is I guess the
closest to master and so has the most
the least likely to kind of collide an
internal changes out that's it
absolutely but it's definitely worth
three emphasizing that submitting
changes to an existing release as an
external contributor it's very unlikely
that things will be accepted unless ur
going into the compatibility test suite
and CTS because a lot of the development
for releases which are made like jelly
bean has already been frozen so there's
there's not going to be big features
added to it or anything else like that
so it's always worth adding new stuff in
master rather than picking a specific
release those questions you answer them
hmm so Sam from Florida asks on
moderator what's the best advised way to
sync timing an app for example switching
rotation while the timer is running is a
service the best way to do a service is
definitely a refill to the author of
ultimate stopwatch stopwatch app on the
Play Store yeah ask rich this question
so I do it all in on port along with you
so ladies sanity I say to share
preferences in on board a lot to do is
I'm excited I don't do nothing like the
embarrassed they're not having my own
application store but I do have an
install so
the nice thing about using on pause
along with you is this the app is going
you can hit 21 seconds later you can hit
the home button and it looks like it's
gone into the background then it's still
running and when you go back to it it'll
have carried on from it looks like it
scared on the background terra turns to
33 seconds well that's all just faked
through on pause I just store the
current time on the clock as well as the
current real time and then resume I just
sell it back to where it would be here
on air we gonna commit to adding the new
jelly bean and notification chronometer
API a very uncounted in my state of
Lillian my notification bar so he goes
into the background we could have
counting going on in the notification
bar and exactly to this point when we go
into we rotate I do the encores on
resume stuff as well see using share
preferences I never an idea as commented
in the moderator is using the bundle
which is passing on destroyed you can
say it in that bundle there's also if if
it's not necessarily showing the time
using the alarm manager to set future
events if they're just looking for a way
of saying in 15 minutes I want something
to fire off that's a fantastic point out
because ultimate stopwatch also has a
countdown timer load and when you switch
modes to countdown timer and you put
your time of one minute in again it's
counting down and when you do that it
actually shuts the abdomen this time its
uses the alarm manager to set an alarm
for 58 seconds time so the camp am still
the soon at it and it looks like it's
counting down in the background but
actually the app shut down it's just
using the alarm manager I wait about to
go off in a minute to check it still
working I haven't tested it an agent
yeah but yeah the chronometer at rich
notifications things very good idea cat
nap time is gifted in poached eggs I use
it for well the new thing in London lab
yeah Thames Water want everyone to share
within four minutes so you could put
your phone inside edge if you inside our
freezer back and use a pen for counting
down your formula shower and saving
water and then maybe use ice bucket lift
this week on geek you up that
my other rats also trick you like the
good source code the ultimate stopwatch
is also a consult on google code so you
can just look through the code for that
and see how it's done so a service I
think I service sounds like a bit of a
heavyweight approach I haven't had I
have another so you know now most apps
you have the when you're paying for one
or even a free one the e on the EU la
you know the user and user agreement is
there anything you know I haven't looked
in the open source project is there
anything like the framework is going to
just come up with that so there's a
consistent one look where you just put
in your user agreement isn't it I mean
isn't that kind of canned you put in
something that way II wish you lady till
them out um the end user agreement so
more like I accept or don't accept some
kind of standard thing that you could
call to like an AP eyes and you know
instead of rap you mean one this guy
sharing it when you launch not for
example yeah so they would be something
that's given to you by the Play Store so
you could it takes you to the Play Store
in the Play Store says yeah and saves at
just like with your you know in-app
purchases to this mat so it's something
that it would manage instead of you have
to manage that in your you know you're
already doing it for the day that's an
interesting areas because like we
actually handling the air patches you
know so we know what's going on there
and we can you know be confident that
you look colors that if it's some
behavior which your app then goes on to
do like I don't know if we could suggest
some legal text that sounds kind of
murky to me I do know there's some
templates out there for you know solve
Arthur's like to you know don't have the
resources to engage your lawyer to write
these things for them so I noticed some
might kind of creative commons licenses
out there where you basically go through
and you know fill in a wizard send your
app name and what you want to do it will
give you some standard ones for like
location-based app and you know whatever
app the I'm not talking about the text
i'm talking about just a part of the API
where that all play store and you pass
in that verbiage so i'm not even what
be a lawyer standard so we do have it
for privacy policies already but of
course privacy policies don't need to be
accepted by the user explicitly in the
same way that end user license
agreements usually do so at the moment
you're right it's still up to the
application to provide a dialogue or
some kind of acceptance so they can see
the end user agreement and then accept
it explicitly there and have a time
stamp whatever um nice the ones I've
seen tend to just be a scrolling text
view with an ok or cancel button at the
bottom yeah that's what I have on my one
app but I'm just in hooks like it would
be nicer to be able to say a third party
it also a third party has captured your
agreement to it's not something in my
app that I could have manipulated well
when you get lawyers involved in good
news I don't like we do notice the
permissions for that someone is when you
hit install it pops up saying these the
permissions that use and you have to sit
you know except except install you can
tell them that level yeah something like
that what here's the end user agreement
to boom so it's something I feel out in
the Play Store not in the app itself and
then I can say to the lawyer you know
when someone's to look I you know I
didn't mean if you like to send my code
here's the timestamp to choose timestamp
because look it's managed by the Play
Store Oh interesting I guess it's called
a lot of infrastructure on and support
from our side if we did build it we need
to give you access to the list of users
that it accepted it which versions of
your unit accepted when they accepted it
and all that kind of or I wouldn't even
need that I'm only thinking length i
hope i get sued or something like that
then yeah i would say go to google and
make a request for maybe something like
that like where you can make a request
because it's not going to be like
something i need like that I just need a
you know this is going to be if it's a
long battle you just say hey here and
make a formal request and get it
interesting because I don't know why I
would need it unless you know okay hello
what we sit next to earlier to the play
publisher site email mention it to them
I say you know I you shooting
who knows whether they've had that
suggested before or not they got a lot
of feedback this kind of feedback quite
recently when they were over at Google
i/o which they're looking through but
I'll definitely add it to the list
feedback and see what they say ah do we
have any more moderator questions best
child suggesting ideas can make it I
have a library project okays it's like a
new one I have a library project this is
from Dave with a content provider and
multiple application project that
reference the library I can't install
both client applications at the same
time because of the content provider any
suggestions on how to solve you need to
use a different name space for the
content provider in each app yeah the
content provider you can't have the same
content provider twice on the device it
wouldn't make any sense so the content
by that I mean it's like saying that
your two acts of the same package name
it's just not going to work we're gonna
have to create the two asset building on
the library of different package names
and give the namespace of the content
provider actually the namespace of the
content provider should often include
the package name anyway into the same
namespace so there should be different
it would be I mean it'd be pretty
confusing to a user to have to content
providers providing different data in
the same namespace I mean it's I can't
see ever use where you'd want to do it
how'd you know which one you're talking
to yeah yeah okay there's another new
one in there at the moment I use a
fragment class in five tabs I want to
know what the tab is being created in
the background what the tab yet what the
tab is being created in the background I
realized DVM create two tabs even though
it has five EG i click on tab 3 the tab
1 will be destroyed and tab for will be
created in the background but still be
uh I'm guessing it's the dalvik virtual
machine okay yeah area I hope you guys
understood the question because I'm not
too sure what's being asked so I think
it's basically asking well because us
use an adapter rights and adapter will
supply views and only kind of
instantiate them as when they're needed
so that you know you can handle
arbitrarily large data sets I think
that's your major problem he looks know
why aren't what all five up created it
sounds like or I think you want to know
when the tab is being created or which
ones being created next yeah I mean he's
the one who's providing the layout oh
really understood ah ok I've tad thank
you using a few pager ASEAN teenager
fetching hematochezia news major then of
course you've got to provide the pages
yeah it will say once you get to page
three page one gets to that and page 4
will be requested so you can keep
swiping through them all and you can set
how many in tabs and advance to the
question is is it using a view pager or
if you just got five times in each one
pass each one has a fragmented it if
that's the case then there isn't any
preloading that I'm aware of so it won't
be shuffling tap one out of memory and
loading tap for when you click on tap
three unless you do have some kind of
adapter in place and a view pager and
these kind of thing yeah
I think it depends view page if it's
just a new layer that you sort should
get in stature than one yeah and also
their your fragment so you'll know when
their life cycle is changing well that's
exactly one we need more details in this
perhaps if you could post a bit more
information yeah myself you play some
more information may be of some code
samples to stack overflow and link to it
in the moderator that might help us any
a bit more information to go on here as
a few different scenarios around that
okay anything else in the comments
before we or any other questions from
the or inside the Hangout if not I'll
have a look for clients and maybe we'll
close up early keeping ourselves time to
feed Bradley Bradley Wiggins in the
Olympics right not that we're legging it
off to go watch the Olympics what room
set up internet okay what you said that
washer ah it's all right what about
Phelps is everyone Knicks is that a big
thing yeah yeah and I get anything it's
gonna be broken oh he knows a swimmer
seemed to you know be able to compete a
lot of events ecosse nice watching the
Olympics on my Nexus 7 right now I
didn't get to go to Google i/o um yeah
I'm really impressive also yeah it must
be another swimmer who if anyone is
gonna be that right yes no one else
needs to do as many events like is it
his third game for second the roads seem
to be in for quite a lot yeah but yeah
but they say was it 19 medals exact now
hmm that's incredible you have the
previous record the russian girl i'm
sure i remember a name was like 34 years
ago or something like that what did she
do she was gymnastics ha it is a lot of
different events you have team events
and your separate you know personal
events be nice
well I'm cheering for Bradley or sister
will be his he'll be almost medal one
pester ever for Britain if he went today
today will be actually we are very much
enjoying the Olympic so we may over the
whole time one final question from
Gatlin just came in saying can you
provide a example of a very simple
privacy policy I don't have one I
imagine if you looked on the internets
floor one what would come up pretty
easily for standard privacy policies
things like that also you can aground on
android apps for privacy policies but
unfortunately i don't i don't think we
have one I here found you someone in my
stream someone might keep the street
said something just like that Creative
Commons privacy policies familiar well
it's-- department well but isn't it also
depending on the content that you have
in your app is the type of privacy
policy you have to have an agreement to
so it's very specific to your app isn't
it there are some quite large
encompassing umbrella ones that
basically say we're not going to share
your data with third-parties we're not
going to distribute it rani internet
we're not going to post it on our local
notice board those kind of ones tend to
be reasonably okay for most things but
there are there are some complexities in
it because it's in certain countries you
can't put into a privacy policy certain
things because you have to hand over
information to legal agencies and all
the rest of it so yeah gets tricky I'll
try and find the linker that I was
talking about it and share it after this
session but I will also carry out that
no one here is a lawyer so they take our
advice yeah FF is this this their fix
amateur commentators australia is just
left the traps so long as we know with
all these patent wars they're evil
thanks for coming in today David it's
been great to talk today sorry questions
as well and helping out feel free to
come back in any other time you are your
me invite this now and a interesting
thing is the creative commons is privacy
policy is creatively commons licensed
testing howard s it yeah alright thank
you all very much for watching today if
you've got questions for next week
please start populating the moderator
and will be
back 2 p.m. gmt next wednesday thanks
guys enjoy the cycling thank you so much
do i buy